welcome to the 7:30 class okay and we
the theme of this class we take a look
at the game from 21st century and I
actually found this game played a few
days ago here at the club sinkhole Cup
tournament most of you probably seen the
game but you saw that karana won but
maybe didn't quite understand all the
ideas all the ideas or the subtleties
how he managed to win the game so and I
will explain to you it was a great game
by Carolina positional game and he won
and Lucas's only winning the tournament
so he had eight draws and he managed to
win this last game so let's take a look
let's take a look to see how it happened
he 45 96 his opponent is giddy on each
key and we should be five a-six so we
have which opening Roy Lopes opening
right Bishop a4 Knight f6 castles and
Knight takes e4 Bishop e7 is another
move in this position Bishop e7 then
rook e1 v 5 Bishop e3 but he played
Knight takes e4 this is called the open
Spanish here and this leads to a force
sequence couple of four sequence move d4
d5 this should be three and it's very
risky to open up the e-file because rook
e1 will come in and it's going to be big
problems like for example if you take
then there could be some even Bishop d5
Titans
big big problem here so you don't want
to do that so he played d5
took Bishop e6 he played Bishop e6 to
protect the defy pawn so Queenie 295 and
here looks like here it was a rare bit
more rare move that her on a plate but
the be honest with you the move looks
very logical because white is trying to
open up the C file yes most people
probably would just take back with a
pawn to open up data but he did the
opposite he took back to the C pawn and
that way he can play Bishop to e3 and
open up the position you know use the C
file to his advantage of course if black
manages to have this pawn on c5 he will
be better and we should be certain
cancer but unfortunately he doesn't have
a good way of getting his pawn on c5 so
now c7 pawn is backwards and the knight
on c6 is vulnerable so there's a
backward pawn we have on c7 and we have
a vulnerable knight on c6 here as well
okay so we see some problems here so
Bishop e7 93 developing is Knight
castles dish of III white is just
developing his pieces two good squares
and getting ready to play okay c1 this
kind of positions is very difficult and
could be very annoying for black to play
because you really want your pawn on c5
years if you can I get your pawn on c5
you're always going to be worse you
always going to be basically suffering
here because he is just going to put
pressure on you on the open files the C
file and the D file Queen d7
I remember perhaps during the game I was
analyzing this position a little bit and
f6 was a very important move to play for
giddy which he didn't do he had to take
measures and play f6 quickly to try to
eliminate this if I pawn and looks like
this was the best way for him to try to
equalize the game so perhaps perhaps
even here he had to play the f6 no but I
don't think he did it yet
well if you have a pawn on c5 imagine
you can play d4 you can start marching
down the pawns
so that's why you're trying to do this
so that's why you well he's going to try
he's going to try it's not easy it's he
can try but it's not so easy it takes
time to do that ok you have to move the
knight it's too much pressure going on
here there is a pressure on the d5 there
is a pressure on a c5 a lot of pressure
going on so that's why it's not so easy
to do that right rook ad it yeah this f6
idea was very important for giddy to
play I believe and to try to equalize
the game so Luke t2 by car 1 yes f6 is
his get rid of the e5 pawn and when you
have bishops you like open file so you
want to open the position and that opens
up the position it gives a little bit
more freedom and activity to his bishops
in the game hindi didn't do that and he
was really throughout the whole game
under under a lot of pressure so that's
why he actually did that later sorry
actually he did a little bit later but
he should have done this earlier that
was waiting in fact he did that I think
he just did that now but he did a bit
too late he had to do it earlier like
even maybe here at 6:00 after Queen d7
like this was the best timing to do it
carvanha doubled and now he simply goes
for this line it's a force sequence rook
88 90 xe5 90 X e5 pawn takes e5 95
now white is lined up on a D file he's
threatened discovery checks is setting
all kinds of ideas so giddy decided to
go for this position
fifty-five if black plays Bishop d6 is
just still gonna be worse yes I was
watching live in bed triangles that are
clearly six room
here well we need six was probably
better try in this position position is
still worse or black there is no
question about it I'll explain why but
but let's okay let me show you this
first because then I will talk about
this
usually when you can get the rooks two
rooks were acquainted it's usually good
you're safe but in this position the
problem was he could never exchange the
bishops if he could exchange the bishops
then he'll be fine but he could never
manage to exchange the bishops and with
the bishops on the board it was a zero
control a four-block in the game it was
a zero come to play that's why he lost
the game okay so our queen is six okay
this move is also worse because after
take take rook c1 and now we see
problems on this C pawn we see a problem
on a pawn a lot of problems we are
seeing in the position okay so this is
not really this is far from equality
here okay still there is a pressure
gauge pressure for white and he he
doesn't have almost he doesn't have any
weaknesses and black has one more extra
island and obviously some weak pawns
here okay
so giddy went here he was you know he
thought okay I'll be slightly worse but
I can probably hold this position in
some point I will swap the bishops and
after I swap the bishops or probably
there will be some chances to hold okay
but he never managed to do that now
excellent move by Caruana Queen c2
attacking the weak pawn on c7 but most
importantly which move he is stopping
make excellent he's stopping Bishop c5
remember the conception here black wants
to exchange the bishops after he does
that with two rooks he can hold the
position if it's like equal material of
course if he loses a lot of pawns then
he's going to lose again so but that's
the idea so now the threat is Queen c6
attacking the a6 pawn attacking the rook
so it's becoming some problems there
yeah so that's why black head to play c5
blockhead to play c5 here and now what
did he play here you remember yes what G
324 is not going to run away he wants to
play g3 to have a proper lift for this
King and it's not point play h4 to take
away this Bishop h v g5 exchange forever
and now even though again what is the
value of the two rooks ten pounds right
the value of two rooks value of the
Queen is mine but this is one of those
examples perhaps rare you know I would
say I would even call it rare example
that where block is really worse in this
position
clock is really worse here because the
main main idea his worse is he doesn't
have any control play so that's why it's
very important to have contra play when
you're playing these positions so that's
the idea yes why isn't that
very well no because if you trade the
bishop's right you with two looks you'll
be able to attack on f2 and create
contra play but with this Bishop sitting
here is cementing his position he is
cementing the position and he can't do
anything so that's why it's very
important to it's like a little game
black ones to exchange the bishops White
is doing everything he can to stop it if
we take the bishops off the board black
shouldn't have that many difficulties
holding it to a draw yeah so that's the
idea
yes so that's the idea to play c5
so c5 was necessary okay and also this
beef if we put this fun on b7 right no
problems whatsoever that's why I
remember each palm push it's like a
commitment okay you make a commitment
and then if we can if this pawn was on
p7 Amish kid would play c6 and he could
not do he wouldn't lose this game you
would just be rock-solid but one palm
push on b5 creates a huge difference c5
g3 this is just to get a proper lift on
g2 and also play h4 it goes King h8 h
for expanding expanding he wants to also
continue pushing yeah
rookie King h8 the reason behind it
because light squares are weak and at
some point is afraid to get pinned and
some checks and pick up the pawn its
prophylactic move but in reality the
problem for Givi is he doesn't have a
contra play that's the main problem in
this position it's amazing with two
rooks
and you know doesn't look like that
better opposition but zero contra play
and that's the main problem when he lost
this game and it was really a smooth
victory for Caruana you don't see this
kind of very smooth victories at that
level you know when to almost 2800
battling each other you see you know
they're always somebody trying to do
some contra play but in this game it was
just nothing
24 now centralization it's just look how
beautiful the Queen is only four is just
attacking the rook attacking the weak
pawn buying this weakness in a weak pawn
in h7 pressure here and again blockading
black can't even push the pawn anymore
h6 and our King G to another
prophylactic move here and
now Kawana is preparing g4 g5 push to
expose the position of the black skin
that's what he's trying to do Bishop f6
King h3 you can push the pawn on g4 g4 b
g4 because you'll drop the pawn if you
play h5 then you don't really have much
of a counter play so that's when he goes
King to h3 and now treating to play g4
g5 okay let's not make any noise please
so g5 h5 now the move itself looks
completely bad yeah looks like why did
he do that he's going to lose the pawn
but he just didn't know what to do
against this idea push push and expose
the king and the attack
I mean h5 move it's he's certainly going
to lose the pawn but he should have
probably not played Age 5 yes absolutely
agree with you excellent that you point
out h5 move
that was excellent yes absolutely he
played h5 because he wanted to prevent
white from advancing absolutely that's
what he is trying to do to prevent it
but the problem is that point is just
going to be so weak that you're going to
lose it it's not like he had a better
move here but h5 seems like is just kind
of kind of you know we expedite the
process here perhaps yes
like what when they're live this might
be the best time he could do it no I
take no I think you have to put the
[ __ ] one at six maybe you have to play
route default here you could play the
snow certainly but I don't have to take
you that's one thing I don't I'm not
forced to even take you I could take you
I could take you hypothetically
he takes then then some contact play and
some quantum play here so you go here
you push push no not so clear who is
actually willing here looks like Bach
might be suddenly winning okay
well it's certainly a very interesting
move rook before I believe that Annie
should have tried this h5 is it's just
bad yeah you should have tried it before
but I don't think a karana was going to
take this pawn I think it was simply
going to take Queen v7 and then start
collecting the Queen side pawns yeah
Queen c6 yeah probably Queen Queen c6 is
excellent yes I agree they're just
winning upon now that's the reason he
didn't play that I'm sure a player like
be reconsidered this exchange sacrifice
but he just didn't see a point I mean
what is he really going to accomplish at
the Queen c6 white is just simply going
to collect upon one of these pawns and
that's it
so h5 was played okay how are we going
to win this though we're saying white is
dominating and but how are we gonna win
this and make sure we do the job right
to not allow any contra play yes
wait Oh f3 oh you could play after
worried what are you trying to do with
the f3 you could play f3 yes that's a
possible move yeah
f3 is a possible move you can try to do
that but the problem is it's kind of
weakens the position you know so that's
why you don't want to play f3 it will
weaken your position a little bit I
would like to keep the pawn on f2
because it's protecting my position okay
so that's why it's important to keep the
pawn on f2 so remember that if you push
the pawn and exit then it's going to be
a little bit of contra play with drug
did 3 yes a force creating additional
witnesses that's what he's trying to do
26 you will always have it he cannot
secure the square
so what Caruana is trying to do is
trying to create additional weaknesses
on the Queen side loosen up the position
you say yeah that's the Russian chess :
one weakness is not enough to win you
have to create the second one here he's
creating the third one probably you know
because there's just weakness here
weakness here I mean we know that more
weaknesses opponent has more chances you
can have to win without much difficulty
so that's why you want to try to create
as many weaknesses as possible okay and
that's why a four is doing very patient
play by Corona is not just going up the
pawn he could have done that but he's
not rushing on that matter Luke d3 now
dd has been sitting basic the past 10
moves trying to defend the position so
finally he is saying okay let me try to
get some kind of contra platelets going
takes now we have couple of loose pawns
here as well Queen g6
trying to pick out that h5 pawn right b4
black don't know what to do so just
trying to toss the pawn in and try to
take the B to pawn or something check
goes here
Queen f5 now he pick up the hy pawn now
he is after the e4 pawn again the the b3
pawn cannot be taken because of the
check so that's why I he took on b2 we
need force as you can see now blocking
is getting more exposed here with only
one pawn being there Luke is under
pressure c5 pawn as well the only way
for block is to try to again get this
bishops off the board and that's what
he's trying to do he's tossing the pawn
in to liquidate the Queen side in the
hope that he can exchange the bishops
and somehow try to hold but the problem
for him is his King is now very exposed
group d5 and g4
now let's stop here for a moment and try
to understand how white can win this
position you have three points versus
one but two rooks are active and we know
that black is going to try to exchange
the bishop to create some more chances
because at the end of the day if you
have only one extra pawn you might not
be able to win in the king of on endgame
for example so what para Juana is trying
to do here and he did this very well he
just expanded his pawns
he just pushed G for it he just expanded
the pawns to to basically come forward
and open up this King and create making
threats that's why he is just advancing
the pawns so now he goes King h8 now he
continued who can mention what this pawn
on d5 is doing that is very important in
this position what is the pawn on g5
doing here
besides gaining space what is it doing
yes
that she's doing that too but also be
sure to had a stable square right Bishop
had a stable square on f6 that he could
just put it there and not to worry about
anything now he doesn't have that squish
so this Bishop now everyone doesn't have
now a stable square any longer
okay that's what just happen now DD
plays Bishop d4 and looks like he's
accomplishing that task of a changing
the bishop but the problem is now
Caruana spawns are too advanced
we take Queen f7 preparing some more
attacking ideas check and g6 he just
wants to go Queen check and g6 rook d7
this is from not a good move it's losing
right away there were some ways maybe to
pull up a little bit more resilient
defense here perhaps suddenly the rook
t5 you know that might have been a
little bit better because what we did I
think it was in time travel so you just
allowed this trick and g6 now Queen h7
check will pick out the 3rd pawn and
three connected passed pawns there's no
chance so here perhaps a little bit more
resilient defense could have been maybe
something like rook four to route d4 to
d5 and try to put some pressure
white white will probably still win with
King g4 and prepare the f4 but it would
be a little bit more work yes question
because he's gaining he's trying to make
a forty moves that's why uh well yeah
you just you just wanted to make the
time control get that get it over with
that's why there's no bigger reason why
he did that he could have played that
right away I agree but this way he made
time control he just sat there think
about it he doesn't have to worry about
the time now G six nine one still Queen
eight seven check and Queen h8 that's
what he's trying to do now this g7 palm
cannot be protected and when g7 upon is
gone that's it you cannot defend this
position so it was here check
now three connected pawns get is still
trying to hold but when h8 is excellent
move keeping the King away so he can I
get closer now getting ready to push and
promote the pawn check king h2 not here
okay because that would be a blunder
rook g4 checked except upon you go here
again rooks cannot coordinate here if
they were a little bit differently
placed maybe he would have some chance
but now G pawn is just simply gonna push
down G seven and eight
so now after King h8 I believe he
resigned and this victory actually
helped karana to finish tie for second
so it was important win big difference
in a prize money as well each win in
this tournament was huge so but the
casino there were not as many decisive
so best lease all won the tournament
with two wins and seven drawers so a lot
of people came only half a point behind
him but it shows how close it was you
know this place they just play this year
like four days ago yeah
four days ago they played this game and
yeah Fabiano won and unfortunately for
giddy was another bad tournament and so
he is he hasn't been playing that well
last two tournaments at least so his
rating is going down a little bit okay
so this was the game of caranas victory
against giri we have time for one study
so I want to give you one study at the
end some good study to work on okay so
let's see if you can find a way to save
the game this one it looks like a very
difficult position looks like your
knight is trapped and you have but
you're going to have a way of saving
this game okay all right why to play why
to play and you need to make a draw here
okay
huh or you've seen this one before okay
well just try to remember the solution
then it's not so easy even if you seen
it a while ago it still would be good to
review also white to play and draw the
problem the night on a 8 is trapped it
cannot go back that is the problem your
night is trapped and if you don't play
this correctly you will lose your night
and of course you lose the game
okay well let's let's give everybody a
chance to solve this don't rush let's
give it a little chance okay a lot of
these studies they have this idea that
at the end it ends with a steel bed okay
sometimes you don't think you can do it
but there are positions where you can
force your King somewhere that in order
to improve the position he has to still
meet you all otherwise you will have to
he will lose his last piece so that's
the idea to remember the first idea I
think first which bit you know you have
you need the first move to create any
chances because it looks like it's just
hopeless
one two I take it and I have the right
color bishop
I have the right color bishop everybody
so that's important if this was a light
square bishop yes you could make a draw
it was the wrong color but what you need
to do first issue a for excellent
excellent job yes a for now you want to
play a five and get the night on b6 so
if you let you do that you're going to
sack the night if he takes with a pawn
his last point is gone so that's a draw
no pants no wind if it takes this way
you take if they see the King we know
the side point you cannot win just King
will sit in front you cannot win if it
takes with this you can win this
position if if King gets in front of the
palm but unfortunately he can never do
that
you will oppose him and then you will
make a draw here and so he has to play
the move a5 absolutely necessary now
what to do
and very important to play this move
first before you you go for another idea
Kingda tree the problem you lose now
after this move because you go here I
face your king c6 and you are in what we
call it in
super 196 I go be the bishop and this
trick doesn't work here because I have
Bishop II one Bishop e6 the draw King a
cig that's the that's the solution
actually that's the solution but how we
can achieve that see very directly King
the tree doesn't work and here by the
way you in sucks one so you go here
it just goes here it takes you and he
goes here sucks one so aha excellent
excellent
in between move Intermezzo yeah attack
this guy if it goes away then we simply
move the knight out if it was somewhere
here he is going to be on the way okay
so he has to go now here or here doesn't
matter these are the two square she can
do now what do we do now
excellent excellent we are coming here
to win the pawn so he has to go here now
97 King b53 Bishop cannot defense on the
side anymore so it has to go here
6 we should cannot move you take the
pawn Kings e6 stalemate got it
that is the idea to remember it looks
impossible
it looks like completely hopeless with a
knight on a but again that's why we do
studies ok that's why we need to do the
studies to improve on our imagination to
see more ideas how we can try to salvage
you know and get a draw in a position
that looks completely hopeless I just
serve
this week somewhere it said that players
like building openings and tactics for
grandmasters new studies yeah absolutely
okay well excellent everybody well thank
you everyone for coming and hope to see
you next week okay